こんにちははじめ社長です久しぶりのドッキリでございます
まぁまぁまぁまぁだ手書きましょうずっとしたかったんだけど結構アレなんですよ
仕掛ける人に
夜タイプなんで撮ったようにバシッと決まると思いますよ
じゃない
こいつはやべぇこれはねー
九尾シートもねー
と黒へび
いやー山いう文はこんな感じです
俺さあこの子の男児がダメなんだよ
俺おいだろうおりこれを予約
じゃあぞうんいや俺これからあの一件おもちゃっぽいと思うんですけど
うわぁああマジで山へ
俺これ無理ないけどかめゴムの感じが素材がいい感じ年なんか結構落としたらなら蛇
っぽいんですよ
尻尾とかもなんかこの感じがも蛇なっちゃってるんで
かなりヤバイお礼ねこれされたらね死んじゃうねだろう
多分でが色でしまっあのドッキリあのアーマーしちゃだめだよドッキリは猫のかけるが
輪っか県れる母の信頼関係を踏み出すことなんだよ
うんちょっと動いてねーって今回ですねこのた以上の蛇
を上から落としますもうすぐ後輩が来るんでこの大量の蛇を上から落とします今回は
リアルです
日
ファットにちゃったいや倍もこーんなになぜだってベビーレーサーじゃんもう
フィギュア
はいっていう意味だよもうすぐ来ると思うんで早速も仕掛けます
はい的で漢字だけとりあえず伝えておきますたぶんもうすぐ来るんでそれをご結構の
ヘビを持って
上にいますあいつが来そこから入ってきたがバッグって下ろします
素振りあるだ入って感じでいこうと思いました
しばしお待ちください中国に連れてってやるぜー
バンドソーセー前かはい下がってます
はい
はいアイドルよ
あっはぁん
wh
ただん
ああああああ
mar
ん
マッスル以降でしょ
昔からダメ in dutch やっ